hey guys my name is Jess it is the 23rd
of February and Dan is moving the camera
too fast
slow down slow down I have another guy
okay but stop mourning tender switch
launch titles have been announced as
part of its a shop announcements today a
Nintendo reveals more titles that are
set to arrive on switch when it comes
out on the 3rd of March which is also my
birthday haven't really brought that up
before now because it's not really
relevant but I'm kind of salty at
Nintendo about it anyway new launch
games shovel knight treasure trove which
includes the original trouble night and
all DLC including Spectre torment will
arrive on switch on the third earth
treasure trove and Spectre of torment
are exclusive to Nintendo switch for a
limited time the star MX will also be
arriving at launch and is described as a
lightning-fast anti-gravity racing game
that features local split-screen and
online multiplayer it will be exclusive
to the switch next up I've got good news
for those of you with no instant
connection one TV one couch and three
friends the next hailer will have
split-screen
unlike Halo 5 which featured no
split-screen option Microsoft has
confirmed that the next game in the Halo
series will support split-screen
multiplayer three for three industries
executive Bonnie Ross said during a
speech at dice 2017 that not including
split-screen was one of the painful
learnings they faced after taking over
from series creator Bungie she went on
to cite the must achieve collections
poor launch as another painful learning
saying struggles like this are
incredibly painful for the community and
for us and it erodes trust it was
technically impossible for split-screen
to be added to Halo 5 after launch in
part due to the games locked 60 FPS
frame rate while no new Halo has been
announced rust has stated for any FPS
going out forward we will always have
split-screen in finally today Kojima has
given us a little more insight into
upcoming ps4 game death strandings
Kojima says that death stranding will be
an open-world game that gives players a
lot of freedom
adding you can think of death stranding
as an action
games he said the goal of the game is to
be very intuitive so players can jump in
easily although Kojima also stressed to
the death stranding will offer a certain
new type of depth and it aims to be
something that players may not have seen
before
Kojima explained you have a lot of
freedom of choice to do what you want to
do and you can get in vehicles and so on
if you're a fighter that's plenty of
opportunity for that if you're not that
kind of player there are other ways to
play this game hopefully that means I'll
be able to fulfill my fantasy of taking
Mads Mikkelsen out for a nice dinner
Kojima also suggested death stranding
may have a non-traditional online
component as he said while many games
have a campaign mode and a separate
online mode this game won't be
structured that way he added that the
game won't forced you to play online
which for Hermits like me who vastly
prefer playing single-player games than
interacting with other humans is an
awesome thing that is it for me today do
let me know what you thought of today's
stories head to game spot for news on
battlefield one and I will see you with
our top 5 stories of the entire week
tomorrow